medical experts are saying that
considering his eating habits President
Trump is surprisingly healthy yeah yeah
when told this Melania said okay time
for Plan B now now I want to know what
plan I know yeah and why didn't what am
we kicking to plan B a long time ago it
has come I you've all heard this has
come out that President Trump enjoys
eating cheeseburgers in bed he likes to
eat cheeseburgers in bed
which explains why Melania likes to go
to bed disguised as a salad dressed in
romaine when did he become Ralph I don't
know listen everyone's something this is
a crazy story in an interview former
porn star stormy Daniels that's a great
name sure is former porn star stormy
daniel said she had an affair with
donald trump in 2006 yeah yeah - which
stormy shocked husband said wait you
told me I was your first
you never get you gotta admit I sold
this [ __ ] out of that
I really gave it everything I always
anger there was hurt yes illusion man
fantastic you Andy Andy while crying
over there in the corner I am the
Pentagon is reportedly considering
nuclear retaliation as a response to
cyberattacks by hackers yeah yeah the
biggest biggest challenge is building
missiles that can penetrate a mother's
basement
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm Hawking there's some missile at the
door this is intense during a political
protest of Capitol at Capitol Hill today
82 rabbis were arrested 82 rabbis yeah
that's the first time DC police have
dispersed a crowd by spraying them with
bacon bits
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you